notre invité politique ce matin c'est
roulant Lescure bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes mis délégués
chargés de l'industrie on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour un interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
Ouest-France bonjour Stéphane et bonjour
bonjour on a beaucoup de sujets
d'industrie à voir avec vous évidemment
le projet de industrie verte qui arrive
au Sénat aujourd'hui le salon du Bourget
mais d'abord un mot sur une actualité
qui concerne le gouvernement c'est
encore et toujours la réforme des
retraites j'allais vous dire d'après le
rapport du Conseil d'orientation des
retraites la réforme des retraites ne
suffira pas à résorber le déficit du
régime en 2030 tout ça pour ça non mais
tout ça pour ça c'est déjà ça moi je
dirais heureusement qu'on a fait la
réforme des retraites alors les
estimations du corps ça va ça vient
quand même puisque il y a 7 ans il nous
disait il y a pas de problème il y a
deux ans finalement il nous disait il y
a un problème pendant la réforme des
retraites on a entendu le président du
corps dure finalement il n'y a pas tant
de problèmes que ça
donne un gros problème bon donc et je
jette pas la pierre les estimations
appel actuel c'est compliqué à faire ce
qui est clair c'est que on avait besoin
de faire cette réforme puisque trois
mois après on se retrouve
potentiellement avec encore un petit
problème donc non
République non je pense qu'ils ont goûté
il a fallu trouver un équilibre d'abord
il fallait une majorité au Sénat il
fallait quand même à 49-3 c'est jamais
facile une motion de censure républicain
pour aboutir un 49-3 on a trouvé mais
oui mais le 49-3 ça fait partie je vais
pas vous refaire l'article du c'est le
cas de le dire du processus démocratique
on a des faits une motion de censure à 9
mois après un neuf mois après pardon
donc c'était pas gagné on a eu une
majorité au Sénat le projet de loi a été
validé par le Conseil constitutionnel et
malgré tout ça il y a encore un défi moi
je suis pas sûr qu'il y a un déficit on
verra quand le temps sera passé moi je
suis persuadé que notamment avec ce
qu'on fait sur l'industrie sur la
croissance on va être aussi capable de
générer des recettes supplémentaires
mais en tout cas j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu le monde à l'envers c'est à
dire que pendant des mois on a un
certain aux gens qui me dit il y a pas
de problème il y a pas de problème et
maintenant on va se retrouver dans une
situation vous allez dire mais
finalement vous n'aurez pas fait assez
ça prouve peut-être qu'on a trouvé le
bon équilibre peut-être qu'il faut juste
expliquer que le vrai équilibre ou
déséquilibre de ce régime il est lié à
l'état de l'économie à l'instant T alors
est-ce que est-ce que c'est prévisions
sont pas le reflet de finalement de une
prévision d'une dégradation et de la
croissance et de l'activité économique
en France est-ce qu'on peut pas le dire
aussi comme ça là vous avez raison c'est
que derrière une prévision de déficit
d'un ou de d'équilibre voire même de
surpris un jour qui sait de régime des
retraites horizon de 20,35 ans il y a
des hypothèses démographiques ça ça ne
ment pas hein on maîtrise et ensuite il
y a des des hypothèses économiques des
hypothèses sur les taux d'intérêt c'est
beaucoup moins d'argent voilà et donc il
faut se méfier de ces estimations qui
sont au fond que des estimations il faut
les intégrer comme une évolution des
tendances moi le message que j'entends
derrière cette estimation du corps c'est
que la réforme des retraites elle va
dans le bon sens puisque elle réduit
largement le déséquilibre
non c'est pas sûr moi je le répète je me
méfie allez du balancier qui va d'un
côté puis de l'autre on a une réforme
qui va largement dans le bon sens qui va
contribuer à équilibrer le système
mettons là en œuvre puis on verra
ensuite dans quelques années si un
gouvernement
tous les 10 ans mais il y a un moment où
la démographie va s'inverser comme un
pour l'instant on est au pic je dirais
de l'inversion de la démographie c'est
qu'on va avoir de plus en plus de
retraités et de moins en moins actifs
bon il y a un moment ça va se calmer il
faut faire des bébés notamment c'est le
message on parle industrie le salon du
Bourget tout d'abord qui a ouvert ses
portières inaugurées par Emmanuel Macron
avait déjà une très bonne nouvelle pour
Airbus une commande record la plus
grande commande de l'aviation civile en
volume 500 Airbus des signes compagnie
indienne est-ce qu'on va battre des
records de commande durant ce salon du
Bourget
Airbus on annonce des innovations
technologiques absolument ext pour moi
l'aviation depuis d'ailleurs plus de 100
ans c'est rendre possible impossible
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a 100 ans on rêvait
de voler il y a 50 ans on rêvait de
passer le mur du son c'était le Concorde
aujourd'hui on rêve de faire des avions
décarbonés et on est en train de le
rendre possible et donc il y a des
investissements notamment dans des
nouveaux moteurs safran présente un
nouveau moteur c'est un moteur à hélice
qui va réduire la consommation de 20%
Airbus travaille à des avions propres un
avion qu'on appelle ultra sobre qui va
permettre de utiliser à 100% des
carburants durables on travaille sur les
carburants durables on travaille sur des
avions hydrogène des avions électriques
est-ce que je suis un des principaux
défilés le carburant durable est-ce que
à l'heure actuelle la France importe la
totalité de son capitaine est-ce que du
coup c'est le défi à venir de l'aviation
propre oui mais je pense qu'à à court
terme c'est-à-dire d'ici les 15 20 ans
qui viennent ça peut faire sourire de
dire que c'est le court terme on vient
de parler des retraites mais Patrick
pouyanet de Total nous a dit clairement
qu'il était capable de livrer appelé un
peu plus de 500.000 tonnes il va falloir
produire pour je dirais nourrir le
pourcentage de carburant durable qu'on a
prévu d'intégrer d'ici 2030 au-delà si
on veut passer à 100% de carburant
durable il va falloir changer d'échelle
et c'est pour ça que le Président de la
République vendredi à l'usine safran
annoncé une première autour de l'acte
vous savez où il y avait des gisements
de gaz donc on remplace du carbone par
durable une première investissement dans
une grande usine qui va produire un
carburant durable on peut dire qu'il y
aura d'autres investissements il y en
aura d'autres et surtout moi ce que je
voudrais dire c'est que
on va voir dans les années qui viennent
c'est du boulot il faut investir la
technologie non en fait le défi majeur
ça peut peut-être intéresser vos vos
téléspectateurs c'est que pour faire des
carburants durables il faut recycler
recycler recyclé notamment du plastique
et des déchets on a besoin de recycler
davantage en France on ne recycle pas
assez on ne trie pas assez donc quand
vous triez votre bouteille dans le bac
jaune ou dans le bac vert vous pouvez
contribuer à la production de carburant
en France et la décarbonation de
l'industrie on a dit vous savez que
l'industriéronautique c'est à peu près
3% des émissions mondiales mais les
avions français c'est la moitié de ces
3% puisque on les exporte partout dans
le monde donc on a une industrie leader
dans le monde qui est capable à elle
seule de décarboner la moitié de la
version moderne on devrait en être fier
et je pense qu'on est extrêmement fier
d'avoir ce salon ça fait 4 ans qu'il
avait pas eu lieu c'est un très bel
événement qui va se poursuivre toute la
semaine juste une précision vous venez
d'évoquer les les exportations d'avions
français on a des commandes record
Bourget est-ce que ça va améliorer la
balance commerciale de notre pays qui
est
ultra déficitaire cette année enfin
l'année dernière 174 milliards de
d'euros on a jamais vu ça c'est un
record est-ce qu'on a un espoir de
d'améliorer de rectifier un peu le titre
alors les avions font déjà je dirais
leur part c'est un des seuls exactement
qui cache la forêt alors il y a quelques
armes qui sont plutôt des Beaux-Arts il
y a le luxe le secteur viticole il y a
les médicaments on reste excellentaires
même si non
la seule en fait manière de rééquilibrer
la balance commerciale c'est de Ré
industrialiser c'est de reproduire en
France si vous continuez à faire ce
qu'on a fait pendant 25 ans si a envoyé
la production ailleurs évidemment vous
allez importer votre téléphone vos
micros vos chaises etc si vous dites je
vais industrer les la France d'avoir ce
que c'est bon pour l'environnement c'est
bon pour l'emploi c'est bon pour la
prospérité en plus vous allez produire
des industries en France qui sont elles
capables de s'exporter là on est
vraiment à la réindustrialisation on en
parle beaucoup est-ce que c'est du
discours ou est-ce que c'est vraiment du
contenu c'est du concret mais on a
entamé un virage c'est à dire que c'est
tellement loin exactement on a stabilisé
le bateau on crée de l'emploi industriel
en France 100 000 emplois en 5 ans on
crée des usines en France on en ouvre
plus qu'on enferme 200 de plus en deux
ans mais il faut changer de braquet il
faut accélérer vous savez quand on entre
dans un virage la meilleure manière
d'enseigner d'accélérer c'est maintenant
c'est le projet de l'industriel verte
qui arrive aujourd'hui mais 174
milliards c'est énorme à résoudre il y a
un autour de l'énergie moins on consomme
d'énergie fossile et plus l'énergie
j'irai est autonome donc de l'hydrogène
de l'électricité de la capture de
carbone tout ce qui va nous permettre
d'être davantage autonome des panneaux
photovoltaïques de l'éolien en mer tout
ça il faut qu'on le produise en France
et qu'on produise de l'électricité du
carbone
de modèle français contrairement à nos
voisins notamment pour que les TPE les
PME ne sont pas insuffisamment
exportatrices bien sûr il est en train
de changer ce modèle c'est le virage
qu'on a pris il faut plus de TPE PME ETI
et grandes entreprises exportatrices et
pour ça faut qu'elle soit installées
installées par an chez nous il y a un
sujet commande publique son adresse
aussi dans le projet de l'industriels il
faut qu'on commande à la fois l'état les
armées les services publics les mairies
des produits qui sont environ
environnementalement pardon plus sain
c'est-à-dire qu'ils soient produisent
plus près de chez nous et évidemment si
vous achetez plus près de chez vous il y
a pas mal de chances que vous achetiez
des commandes qui viennent des TPE des
PME des ETI de nos territoires c'est ce
qu'on appelle les ETI les entreprises de
taille intermédiaires qui sont des
normes de très très grosses PME on va
dire enfin voilà basé en région c'est
toujours le maillon faible de la France
notamment comparé à l'Allemagne alors
l'Allemagne de pays dans ces landes pas
nous effectivement on a des très grandes
entreprises notamment dans les rues
d'ailleurs des très grandes on en a
beaucoup des PME des startups on en a
plus que jamais on crée des centaines de
milliers d'entreprises tous les ans et
c'est très bien et maintenant il faut
qu'on les passe à l'échelle et notamment
pour le ministre de l'Industrie c'est un
défi énorme c'est que on part
aujourd'hui des startups c'est plus
trois personnes dans un garage avec une
app sur un téléphone c'est des gens qui
créent des processus industriels mais il
faut les aider à créer ce qu'on appelle
la première usine et ça il y a des
subventions qu'on a mises en place
partout en France et on est vraiment en
train vous savez on a annoncé la semaine
on vivatech
du numérique qui est le plus grand au
monde on a dépassé Las Vegas soyons en
fier l'espace d'une seconde on a annoncé
avec Jean-Noël Barrault la une liste de
125 futurs champions de la technologie
il y a deux tiers de ces futurs
champions qui sont dans l'industrie qui
font de l'avion propre qui font de la 5G
industrielle qui font des produits du
quotidien des vélos etc on crée beaucoup
d'emplois bien sûr alors ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que un emploi industriel
ces trois quatre ou cinq emplois indus
supplémentaires donc on crée de l'emploi
dans l'industrie surtout on en crée
autour on en crée dans les services
parce que pour servir il faut avoir
quelque chose à servir de l'industrie
dans les services publics dans les
écoles dans les hôpitaux on parle des
déserts médicaux moi j'aime beaucoup
parler de ce qu'on appelle les
cathédrales industriels c'est très
belles usines qu'on est en train de
décarboner qui sont présentes partout en
France qui vont j'espère continuer à
émerger et qui permettent autour d'elle
de créer un écosystème de créer
des villes qui se développent des hommes
et des femmes qui viennent travailler
dans la région qui créent aussi du
tourisme bref on est en train de recréer
une dynamique dans les territoires qui
est aussi une dynamique anti colère
l'industrie c'est l'espoir moi je suis
une arme anti colère et je souhaite
continuer à l'être anti colère c'est
aussi une manière de dire
antirassablement le projet doit
industrie verte il a aussi une visée
politique d'ailleurs ça sert vous le
dites vous allez nous le dire peut-être
à lutter contre le rassemblement
national qui prospère là au des usines
fermes c'est aussi ça le but de votre
texte le Front national puis le
rassemble la National qui s'est nourri
de la désindustrialisation donc si on
inverse cette tendance si on redonne de
l'espoir aux gens bah évidemment la
colère va diminuer moi je pense qu'on
battra le Front national désormais
appelé le rassemblement national avec
des faits avec des preuves avec des
actes et cette réindustrialisation d'un
territoire elle est en train de se faire
je vais vous donner un exemple à
Dunkerque on a détruit 6000 emplois
industriels dans une ville qui fait
quelques dizaines de milliers
d'habitants on va en créer 16000 à
l'avenir mais évidemment on va recréer
l'espoir évidemment qu'on va redonner
aux gens envie de croire dans la
politique sur la politique c'est ça
c'est des résultats c'est une capacité à
montrer que en agissant on est capable
de transformer et je pense qu'on va
vraiment montrer qu'on est capable de le
faire parce que on a déjà commencé on
parle pas de rien donc accélérer je le
répète quand on est entré dans un virage
c'est plus facile que de partir de
zéroce les sénateurs on le redire le
texte arrive aujourd'hui au Sénat il
vise à combiner transition écologique et
souveraineté industrielle le rapporteur
du texte Sénat il rappelle que depuis
2001 millions d'emplois industriels ont
été perdus en France comment on redresse
ça un million perdu 100000 gagnés donc
c'est le début c'est vraiment ce que je
disais non seulement on a arrêté le
déclin mais on en a créé en net un peu
plus 100000 depuis 5 ans 10 de retrouver
là c'est l'inverse exactement et donc il
faut dire un de gagner 10 de gagner il
faut secret un million d'emplois dans
l'industrie dans les 10 ans qui viennent
pas 100000 un million ça veut dire qu'il
faut faire 10 fois plus en disant que ce
qu'on a fait en 5 ans donc c'est
vraiment un changement de braquet ce
projet doit il fait quoi il cherche à
simplifier les installations
industrielles il cherche à modifier en
profondeur la commande publique de
manière à ce qu'on achète davantage du
fabriquer en France pour simplifier il
cherche à développer les industries de
demain on a une révolution industrielle
celle de l'hydrogène celle de la capture
de carbone celle des batteries
électriques celle de l'énergie bas
carbone là encore donc il faut doubler
tripler les capacités et ce projet doit
il permet de simplifier tout ça il
suffit pas à lui tout seul en fait ce
projet de loin il accompagne un
véritable changement de mentalité
aujourd'hui la mentalité vis-à-vis de
l'industrie par rapport à 20 ans on
disait l'industrie c'est pour ailleurs
ça pollue renvoyait au bout du monde
c'est ici que ça se passe et les gens
sont en train de de non seulement de de
le reconnaître
mais dit adhérer cette très positif tout
ça mais alors je moi j'ai pas bien
compris vous aviez Elon Musk hier sur le
JT France 2 qui parlait de ses projets
j'ai pas compris où est-ce qu'il allait
installer son usine Tesla en France
moi non plus ce genre de discussion
sera installée
d'investissements à Dunkerque pour une
giga Factory de batterie il y a 4
semaines c'est le président qui était
pour l'annoncer deux jours avant on
n'avait pas d'accord ce genre de
négociation ça prend énormément de temps
beaucoup d'énergie et pour simplifier
tant que c'est pas fait c'est pas fait
c'est pas fait et donc on va être
patient on va voir Elon Musk quand il
envisage d'installer des usines ils
regardent le monde entier on est en
compétition contre le monde entier ce
qui est à nouveau c'est qu'il y a 10 ans
Elon Musk il serait jamais arrêté à
Paris il aurait fait directement
Berlin Beijin
Mumbai il s'arrête à Paris mais bien sûr
il est prêt à regarder aujourd'hui il
est pas le seul la France est le pays le
plus attractif d'Europe là encore soyons
en fier nous faisons le travail avec
Bruno Le Maire avec le président de la
République avec la première ministre
pour
le convaincre parce que la visiblement
il est pas complètement convaincu
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs c'est un des
sujets du projet de industrie verte les
industriels quand ils veulent venir en
France il nous demande trois choses oui
les subventions mais au fond tout le
monde en donne on est là-dessus une
meilleure ni moins que les autres du
foncier des mètres carrés et de la
simplicité de la rapidité d'exécution
pour ça que ce projet de loi il est il
est très important on a fait une petite
parenthèse mais alors il fait plutôt
consensus
des inquiétudes au Sénat notamment sur
qui va avoir le dernier mot sur ces
questions d'urbanisme justement qui va
avoir le dernier mot que les élus locaux
auront toujours leur mot à dire bien sûr
d'abord dans 80% des cas on change rien
c'est le maire qui délivre le permis de
construire ce qu'on proposer c'est que
pour les grands projets national des
dizaines de milliers d'hectares qui
concernent un territoire énergie qui
concerne plusieurs projets on puisse et
ça va être une des discussions avec les
sénateurs après avis du maire pouvoir
simplifier la procédure et faire en
sorte que ce soit l'état qui délivre le
permis de construire évidemment même
dans ce cas exceptionnel le maire le
président d'agglomération aura son mot à
dire on va pas faire de l'industrie
contre les élus locaux moi j'aime à dire
que peut-être mis à part le Front
national se nourrit de la désindustries
ça va être l'objet des discussions qu'on
va avoir avec nos amis sénateurs il y a
déjà des amendements tout à fait
constructifs qui ont été adoptés en
commission on commence l'examen
aujourd'hui donc je vais pas prendre
mais moi j'ai aucune un doute là-dessus
qu'on m'a trouvé un accord l'industrie
française elle a pas de couleur de
maillot les insoumis connaissent pas
l'industrie donc en général il ne l'aime
pas et je le répète le Front national
aura sur la nationale c'est construit
sur la désindustrialisation quand je
vais à Dunkerque quand je vais à Mouvaux
quand je vais dans le Loiret voir
l'usine du relax je peux vous dire que
les élus républicain socialiste même
écologiste et évidemment les Ulis les
élus de la majorité présidentielle sont
tous derrière l'industrie française
parce qu'ils savent ce qui s'y jouent
c'est l'avenir de notre prospérité mais
aussi l'avenir de la transition
écologique en France il y a un autre
sujet d'inquiétude c'est le zéro
artificiel être utilisation net pas
facile à dire bon courage pour cette
genre de séance est-ce que les grands
projets industriels entreront ou pas
dans le calcul des surfaces alors ce
qu'on va faire donc il y a deux projets
de loi aujourd'hui qui sont étudiés il y
a le projet de loi industriel verte et
la proposition de loi de Valérie
detarque est aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée
donc il est très probable que le
compromis se fasse à l'Assemblée qu'on
intègre ces résultats du coup dans notre
projet de loi industriel ce qu'on va
faire c'est que les projets
moi je fais confiance à l'intelligence
collective vous savez j'étais président
la commission des affaires économiques
dans le précédent mandat avec Sophie
prima on a fait 11 CMP conclusive mais
vous vous souhaitez qu'il soit intégré
ou pas dans le calcul moi ce que je
souhaite c'est qu'on puisse intégrer
leur spécificités donc les sortir du
calcul régional et je dirais c'est
partager au niveau national pour les
grands projets d'industrie il est normal
que je dirais tout le monde soit
concerné parce qu'au fond c'est des
projets bien plus larges que les régions
donc c'est vers ça qu'on va aller en
tout cas j'espère il y a aussi des
interrogations sur le financement de ces
mesures d'industrielles est-ce que vous
allez piocher dans l'épargne des ménages
pour financer l'industrie verte non on
va convaincre les ménages d'utiliser
leur épargne pour financer l'industrie
verte l'industrie verte ça paye nous on
va réconcilier fin du mois fin du monde
on va réconcilier économie écologique on
va réconcilier l'investissement dans
l'industrie verte et rendement financier
donc oui on va produire on va créer un
nouveau produit d'épargne qui va
concerner les jeunes qui va s'appeler le
plan avenir climat qui fait que quand
vous avez un enfant qui naît les parents
ou les grands-parents vont pouvoir
mettre de l'argent de côté sur un plan
d'épargne qui va fructifier pendant 18
ans qui sera ensuite disponible à partir
de 18 ans net d'impôts nette de
cotisation sociale qui va permettre aux
jeunes de faire fructifier un capital
avant même qu'il en soit conscient et à
l'économie française
d'investir dans l'industrie de demain
donc c'est du gagnant
oui bien sûr alors un peu l'incitation
quand même d'être dans le pot de
cotisation sociale ça aide
une réduction davantage fiscaux oui pour
la pour ce plan là il sera net d'impôt
net de cotisations donc c'est c'est je
dirais c'est pas un cadeau c'est un
investissement que fait la Nation à la
fois dans l'épargne des jeunes et dans
l'investissement vert donc là encore
c'est du gagnant
de financement au budget pour trouver un
texte le plus consensuel possible
c'est pas pour trouver un texte le plus
consensuel possible moi je souhaite
qu'on essaie débats au Sénat mais c'est
vrai que tout ça va s'inscrire dans le
projet de loi de finances qui va pas
être facile à boucler ça vous a pas
échappé mais mais mais vraiment on a eu
la discussion en audition devant les
quatre commissions concernées du Sénat
on va l'avoir en discussion générale on
a besoin de montrer alors le plan
d'épargne lui il va être créé par le
projet de loi industrie verte mais
effectivement les exemptions fiscales
sont placés dans le projet de loi de
finance et j'allais dire cette bonne
guerre c'est l'habitude un mot sur une
étude de BPI France seuls 29% des
dirigeants de PME et de TI industriels
envisage de recruter des collaborateurs
étrangers dans les 5 prochaines années
est-ce qu'on peut relancer l'industrie
industrielle l'industrie française
pardon son recours à la main d'oeuvre
étrangère non parce que vous dites
seulement 30% mais ça veut quand même
dire qu'aujourd'hui plus d'un tiers près
d'un tiers des entreprises françaises
dans l'industrie considère que pour
remplir aujourd'hui 60 000 jobs et les
centaines de milliers de Jobs qui va
falloir construire corps remplir on va
avoir besoin de manœuvre étrangère ça
veut pas dire ça va se faire au
détriment la mano française on a besoin
d'un million d'emplois dans les 10 ans
qui viennent évidemment une bonne partie
va venir demain offre française qu'il
faut former qu'il faut attirer notamment
des jeunes femmes qui vont pas assez
dans l'industrie on va aussi avoir
notamment pour les personnels qualifiés
avoir besoin
il faut
des textes pour recruter moi je pense à
l'étranger c'est le cas de cette enquête
d'ailleurs il faut que l'échelle
d'entreprise affirment ça parce que ça
va calmer un peu le débat sur
l'immigration qu'on a parfois tendance
un peu à caricat caricaturé pardon
simplifier et réduire aux enjeux de
sécurité et d'immigration clandestine
c'est important de gérer ça mais
n'oublions pas que la France est une
terre d'immigration qui s'est construit
dont l'économie s'est construit sur
l'immigration l'intégration économique
c'est la meilleure manière de réussir
l'immigration et clairement faisons-le
clairement ce que vous êtes en train de
nous dire c'est que tout ça doit passer
par la création du quota pour les
métiers en tension et l'organisation en
fait de cette immigration de cette main
d'oeuvre étrangère aujourd'hui on a
choisi de loi tel qu'il est envisagé
on parle pas de quota mais on parle de
régularisation pour des gens qui sont
aujourd'hui
pas besoin de le faire sur les plateaux
télé ils vous diront ce que je vous dis
aujourd'hui on va en avoir besoin sinon
donc bien sûr bien sûr merci beaucoup
d'avoir laissé notre invité en suivra
bien sûr pendant trois jours l'examen de
ce projet de loi industrie verte au
Sénat merci d'avoir été avec nous la Une
de Ouest-France un plan pour freiner le
tourisme de masse c'est à la ligne de
votre journal Stéphane on passe tout de
suite au club